wo leute ich habe bisher heute schon ein
neues instagram bild eine neue podcast
folge und ein neues tik tok video
hochgeladen allerdings habe ich heute
noch kein youtube video hochgeladen von
der hallo und herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einer neuen episode ebay fels
mit mir veganer ist das jetzt der erste
kleinanzeigen fällt die nicht uns fürs
heutige video ausgesucht habe und zwar
sieht wird schon das ist eine schale mit
geht keine ahnung was das genau sein
soll aber dafür haben wir den titel und
da steht nämlich drin eine schale bis
aktien schalen zum basteln ein euro
verhandelbar ja also ich würde definitiv
zu schlagen das hier ist der nächste
ebay felder und zwar es ist ein
heizstrahler im titel steht allerdings
heinz strahler für 30 euro aus erfurt
und in der beschreibung steht friends
strahler 78 cm h mit schwenkarm in zwei
stufen die erhitzung wählbar
ja wer hätte nicht gern so ein
heizstrahler war allerdings direkt
weiter mit diesem ebay fell und zwar
seht ihr schon das ist ein real madrid
trikot er verkauft das allerdings unter
dem namen adidas fc barcelona ronaldo
trikot in xl und damit herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren episode
luca klatscht wenn man dieses bild hier
auf ebay kleinanzeigen sie denkt man
sich im ersten moment vielleicht erstmal
okay da verkauft jemand jetzt seinen
döner ist ein bisschen komisch wenn man
sich dann allerdings den titel anschaut
wird das ganze noch viel komischer und
zwar sucht dort jemand einen job als
döner
und wer kennt es nicht wenn man halt so
ein döner ist und einfach auf jobsuche
auf ebay kleinanzeigen unterwegs ist das
hier ist der nächste ebay fiel das bild
habe ich euch noch nicht eingeblendet
sondern erst mal nur den titel und die
beschreibung und zwar steht dort
wunderschön zu verschenken guten abend
hier mit biete ich ihnen einen
wunderschönen fuß zu massieren oder
kuscheln an
bei interesse bitte melden und das ist
das foto ich habe bisher nach jedem bild
gefühlt eigentlich nur geklatscht jedoch
machen wir direkt weiter mit diesem
befehl und zwar seht ihr schon dort oben
steht zu verkaufen verkaufen
portugiesischen liga manchmal bellt er
weil er zweisprachig ist man denkt jetzt
vielleicht ok brauchte diese partie das
könnt ihr das denn sein naja das ist ein
shiba inu hinter einem tor durch das die
sonne durchscheinen und deswegen hat er
streifen
kann ich mal aufhören zu klatschen post
mit salami und käse sehr leger zu
verschenken in köln nippes ich haben ein
post mit salami und käse gemacht aber
bin ich satt und das da da brauche ich
glaub ich nichts zu sagen es sind halt
die kölner nahmen das ist der nächste
ebay fehl und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
weiß nicht was das sein soll ist ein
bisschen so aus wie so ein telefon mit
dass man gerade gefühlt bis zum mars
telefonieren kann allerdings steht auf
jeden fall unter dem anzeige bild
geschrieben bei der beliebige geräte von
praxis für 150 euro wird verkauft in
stolberg marke 7.0 funktionen 1 ich weiß
echt nicht was ich von diesem feld
wieder halten soll wir verkauft jemand
eine babyschaukel und ein interessent
fragt ihn hallo was wäre ihre letzte
schmerz preis daraufhin antwortet der
verkäufer 60 euro und der interessent
antwortete daraufhin wiederum eine
grenze ist 75 euro unter mache ich nicht
einverstanden
ok ja super also wenn ich sagen würde
haye diese klopapierrolle hier die
kostet 10.000 euro ihr sagt allerdings
in 22.000 euro die kritik aber auch
kostenlos haben und so habe ich das ja
der letzten liebefeld folge gesagt da
sollte den mich einfach euren instagram
namen kommentieren und einer von denen
dann die chance diese klopapierrolle
zugewinnen von daher bin ich soeben auf
eine website gegangen und habe random
irgendeinen kommentar ausgesucht und
diese userin hat gewonnen
[Applaus]
herzlichen glückwunsch du bekommst einen
in some nachricht von mir dann schicke
ich dir diese tollen körper rolle zu
also das ist ja echt der tag deines
lebens heute machen wir allerdings
direkt weiter mit diesem befehl und zwar
seht ihr schon da verkauft jemand einen
katzen intelligenz spielzeug in der
beschreibung beziehungsweise im titel
steht allerdings intelligent spiel ja
vielleicht solltest du das spiel lieber
spielen und hier verkauft jemand einen
großen goldenen verzierten echtholz
spiegel bzw einen wandspiegel für 280
euro das bild ist allerdings dass hier
irgendwie hat er zwei spiegel und
und hatte ich versteh ich verstehe nicht
er hat dem stehen und feineren spiegel
fotografiert und der dann allerdings
wieder zu zwei raimi bay fels und zwar
erstmal dem hier blau sind die veilchen
rot sind die rosen kinderheim neue
helmut frohsinn und der nächste ebay
reinfeldt es der ihr rosen sind rot ich
schreibe einen song mit dem titel ich
und meine ballweg er meint glaube ich
pavillon aber nah dran
machen allerdings direkt weiter mit
diesem befehl und zwar sieht die schon
im bild das ist eine teufel surround
systeme und bluetooth box von gbl im
titel steht allerdings teufel sound
system und blue dosbox von gbl
ja also ich glaube jeder weiß was du
meinst trotzdem würde ich den
deutschkurs empfehlen sprachenlernen
deutschkurs ihr verkauft jemand aus
erfurt einen sportlichen hamster für
fünf euro und schreibt in die
beschreibung auf tag oder nach der macht
ständig sport und ist viel fitter als
ich er passt nicht zu einem speck oder
wie mir deshalb möchte ich ihnen in
sportliche hände abgeben und das ist das
bild von diesem sportlichen hamster
alles klassiker wobei allerdings gerade
bei tieren sind kommen wir zu diesem
ebay fehlen das ist eine biene maja
kostüm das kann glaube ich jeder
erkennen im titel steht allerdings wie
eine meyer kostüm
ich weiß nicht warum manche leute
einfach nicht schreiben können ist das
irgendwie so ein ding auf ebay und hier
machen auch direkt weiter mit einem ebay
fällt wohl jemand die schreiben konnte
ihr seht schon das bild und den titel
eingeblendet veranstaltungsraum für
verschiedene events da sind jetzt noch
keine rechtschreibfehler drin wenn man
sich allerdings mal die beschreibung
anschaut sieht man schon banketts
verlobung henner abend folter abend
geburtstage goldene hochzeit und
silberne hochzeit
ja da war ein rechtschreibfehler drin
der verheerend ist weil es ihnen
gefunden habt könnt ihr den ja mal gern
kommentieren ihr verkauft jemand einen
gasherd beziehungsweise einen backofen
und ein interessent fragt ihn halo ist
der gasherd voll funktionsfähig und was
für funktionen hat der backofen liebe
grüße und der verkäufer antwortet backen
ja danke für die ausführlichen
informationen und das hier ist der
nächste ebay fällen meine lieben freunde
den habe ich gefunden hat sich airports
eingegeben habe und
ja also für mich sieht das eher nach
einer dusche aus und ich meine ich
könnte jetzt auch nicht so ein großes
also wenn ich mir das an spor packen
würde dann würde ich aus demmin l ich
hasse jetzt allerdings direkt der
nächste ebay kleinanzeigen fell und zwar
seht ihr schon das ist ein doppeltes
chicken mcnuggets verkauft jemand für 15
euro aus pirna und schreibt in die
beschreibung ich habe heute zum sonntag
bei majors eine enorme seltenes chicken
nuggets bekommen es um 2 und einem
rarität 1 zu 100000 stark dass du das
direkt ausrechnen konnte ist das jetzt
der nächste ebay fehl und versehen sie
schon dass jemand ein deutsches
universalwörterbuch verkauft im titel
steht allerdings das duden das duden
universum wörterbuch ich verkaufen weil
sprache zu schwer
naja wer hat das so erfunden das und da
bin ich ganz ehrlich ist die wahrheit
machen wir allerdings weiter mit dem
nächsten ebay kleinanzeigen fehler und
einer person die der deutschen sprache
auch nicht gerade mächtig ist und zwar
verkauft die man dass hier eine couch
wohnlandschaft sofa mit schlaf
funktionen und ein interessent antwortet
auf eine nachricht ich zuvor der
verkäufer geschrieben hat alles klar
und dann schreibt er noch eine nachricht
einige später alles klar
danke afx wieder 10
ja auch wieder zehn leute das ist zwar
kein fell die nicht auf ebay direkt
gefunden habe allerdings wieder an einer
ebay kleinanzeigen gruppe und zwar
schreibt dort jemand ich möchte einen
baby hund in klammern german shepherd
kaufen kann mir jemand helfen ihn zu
finden
also du möchtest einen hund kaufen aber
man soll dir helfen ihn zu finden
zweitens es heißt welpe nicht baby hund
und
dh
auch nicht german shepherd sind hier für
leute unterwegs allerdings auch schon
zum letzten fällt fürs heutige video und
verkauft dort jemand zwei
klopapierrollen auf ebay
und das findet eine andere person nicht
so cool und schreibt daraufhin supergaus
zwei rollen klopapier tiger ehrlich
jetzt ich habe genug klopapier zu hause
und wenn ich welches brauche kaufe ich
es im laden aber du versuchst jetzt in
dieser zeit echt zwei rollen klopapier
zu verkaufen in einer zeit wo
krankenschwestern und müllwerkern oder
sonstige menschen die den ganzen tag
kurz arbeiten müssen sich kein körper
viel mehr kaufen können bald früchte wie
du den ganzen kram auf kaufen weil sie
kam als nick schrägen humor wenn du
eines tages auf dem pott sind weil du
dir vielleicht den angefangen hat so gut
wie creme wünscht weil deine brenner
diskutiert schädlichen eingeführt und
dann plötzlich fest dass sich nur papier
mehr hat ich wünsche mir dass du dir
dann selber begegnet auf baldigen ich
bin komplett meine lieben freunde wenn
ich das heute wieder gerne zu beenden
wenn euch diese häufiger wieso die ebay
fällt es mir gut gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch und ein video
hier dann schreibt immer und in die
kommentare was ihr denkt waren wir alle
wieder raus dürfen bei mir macht die
quarantäne langsam echt zu schaffen
ich glaube das hat man in der heutigen
podcast folge gehört und auch in meinem
heutigen tech talk video gesehen
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto meine lieben freunde hier
ist uns mal die eingeblendet falls sie
noch kein abonnent von meinem kanal zeit
für die da drauf klicken jetzt ist
kostenlos und verpasste keine videos
mehr und ihr seid teil der lupe und hier
ist irgendein anderes video verlinkt
auch dann sicher